all right maurice
maurice oh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally i'm from grandview
missouri
that's near kansas city i think right
yes it is
it's the suburb of kansas city and tell
me about how you grew up you had mom and
dad
i had a mom and dad my grandpa passed
away my grandma my step-grandma passed
away we grew up in a house in missouri
it was green and white
had a garage
was a
three-bedroom house
it had a
master bedroom
had an upstairs had a basement
how would you describe your childhood
um
i grew up on the farm
landscaping
goes back to squash
what kind of kid were you in high school
i graduated in 1973
from ruskin high school in kansas city
missouri
and your childhood no nothing crazy
going on nope pretty solid midwestern
pretty solid yeah
and after after school you went where
go to college college college took
accounting class
the the college is now in phoenix
arizona
goes back to book evening
what kind what kind of work have you
done in your life
mostly landscape
[Music]
goes back to a dead bush
you have you been married before
only once
and i haven't even married her
dear kids
one she lives in moore park her name's
melinda
she has a band classical rock band going
on
and you uh
you've been living here on skid row for
how long
i've been on skid row for about five
months
you've been homeless for how long
a couple of years
how'd you end up homeless
um
camera above my girlfriend's room
put me on the street
what did the camera show
camera shows that i keep going to a room
and doing what
i guess having sex if you want to say
that
there's nothing wrong with that but no
there's not but what got you
kicked out or whatever
i smacked her in the head because she
wouldn't cut her hair
they put a restraining order on me her
mom died
the woman that put the restraint on me
died
that left her alone
she does drugs she does cocaine
she does marijuana
i do marijuana
had a marijuana card the cops took that
do you do any of any of the other drugs
that are out here
no i don't do coke i don't do uh
i just do marijuana cigarettes and
marijuana that's all i do i don't even
drink beer no welcome
no alcohol
have you been on uh
any psych meds before
uh yes i have halidol and
epicot what are those for
uh schizophrenia
are you taking those currently no i'm
not
are you better when you do take them
no i'm not
can i ask you to look at camera there
you go um
what uh what is the difference between
maurice on the psych meds and maurice
off the psychonauts
maurice off the psych meds knows how to
work a job
maurice on the psych meds doesn't know
how to work a job
marisa on the psych meds takes social
security
marissa on
jobs
takes food stamps
lost two food stamp cards already
would you like to go back to uh
the uh park
at echo park and start over with a bar
of soap
direct start with echo park and start
over with a bar of soap
in a bathroom
how do you support yourself living on
the street
panhandle panhandle
you get enough money to eat
uh yes i do
and you'll eat where
you go to the missions to eat or you go
to the summer i go to the mission to eat
when i can
[Music]
do you talk to your family do you have
any contact with anyone
uh
no i haven't i need to write a letter
and i haven't done that
it starts with a black pencil
and an eraser
starts with construction
it starts with a caterpillar
starts with a forklift
especially a forklift
you've been uh the psych meds that you
were prescribed those you were taking
since what age
when did you start taking them
when did i start taking them
1996.
how old are you now
66. you're 66.
born june 2nd 1955
goes back to world war ii
goes back to when hiroshima got bombed
not quite
you're a little bit short of that
yeah i know i am
what uh
what was the best time of your life it
goes back to the japanese when they
bombed us
in world war one
two
or world war ii
goes back to world war one
i don't know what happened to world war
one but it goes back to world war one
what what goes back to world war one
everything
what's your favorite memory in your life
my favorite memory of my life is music
baptist music
about this hymn though
i grew up baptist
it goes back to the complete jewish
bible by david h stern sir
ever heard of david h turn no
david h turns over there in israel
israel's still got a war going on
between the palestinians and the
israelites
it goes back to a jewish flag
they're not flying a jewish flag
anywhere around here
anything else you'd like to know
do you have any friends on the street
uh
yes i do
several
starts with ten dollars i gave somebody
ten dollars the other day
that was homeless
and you stay in a tent or you just you
just swing it
i just wing it right now on the street
homeless with cardboard
no tent
picking up cigarette butts
what's the best thing you found
searching around garbage and trash
uh food
starts with peanuts
started with peanut butter starts with
peanut butter and jelly
what would you describe a good day in
your life now what what constitutes a
good day
finding something to eat
what's a bad day
bad days nothing to eat yeah
how often are you hungry
uh quite a bit
all right you won't be hungry today
how about my swollen feet would you like
to test those
yeah why are your feet so swollen
from walking so much
is that right
from just from walking your feet gets
home just from walking
what'd you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
how to work for a chemical plant
called r d chemical
is that where you worked in kansas city
that's why i was working in kansas city
why are you wearing the uh the coat and
the
internet
because i worked for rd chemical still
i'm still trying to get another job with
them
so hanging out by the greyhound station
parking lot yes sir is that gonna
i'm not sure they're gonna drive by and
hire you
it goes back to collecting trash
goes back to cleaning up the streets
of vale
what do you think l.a needs to do about
their
skid row situation homeless situation
i think they need to do something more
about it
[Music]
goes back to chase bank
goes back to star wars goes back to
redondo beach
library
you know where redondo beach library is
that's where it starts
goes back to redondo beach honda
all right maurice thank you so much for
coming in to talk with me no problem
you have a good day sir you too thank
you
you